where we left off in the last video we'd
actually set up our definite integral to
figure out the volume of this figure so
now we just have to evaluate it and
really the hardest part is going to be
simplifying that and that right over
there so let's get to it so what is this
thing squared well it's gonna have to do
a little bit of polynomial
multiplication here so I'm going to go
into that same color I had so we're
going to have 4 minus x squared plus 2x
times 4 minus actually let me write that
in the degree in the order of the the
terms or the degree of the term so it's
negative x squared plus 2x plus 4 I just
switched the order of these things times
negative x squared plus 2x plus 4 so
we're just going to multiply multiply
these two things I shouldn't even write
a multiplication symbol looks too much
like an X so 4 times 4 is 16 4 times 2x
is 8x 4 times negative x squared is
negative 4 x squared negative 4x squared
2x times 4 is 8x 2x times 2x is 4x
squared then 2 x times negative x
squared is negative 2x to the third
power and now we just have to multiply
negative x times all of this so negative
or negative x squared negative x squared
times 4 is negative 4x squared negative
x squared times 2x is negative 2x to the
third power and the negative x squared
times negative x squared is positive x
to the fourth so it's going to be
positive x to the fourth and now we just
have to add up all of these terms and we
get see we get X to the fourth add these
two minus 4x to the third and then this
cancels with this but we still have that
so minus 4x squared you add these 2
right over here you get plus 16x and
then you have plus 16 so that's this
expanded out and now if we want to X
minus 4 or 4 minus X times 4 minus X so
if we just have 4 minus x times 4 minus
X we could actually do it this way as
well that's just going to be 4 times 4
2:16 time plus 4 times negative X which
is negative 4x negative x times 4
another negative 4x and then negative x
times negative X is equal to plus x
squared so if we were to swap the order
we get x squared minus 8x minus 8x plus
16 but we're going to subtract this so
if we put that if you have the negative
sign out there we're going to subtract
this business so let's just let's just
do it right over here since we already
have it set up so we have this minus
this so we have this minus we're going
to subtract we're going to subtract this
or we could add the negative of it so
we'll put negative x squared plus 8x
plus 8x minus 16 so I'm just going to
add the negative of this and we get we
get and I'll do this in a new color we
get let's see we get X to the fourth
minus 4x to the third power minus let's
see minus 5x squared minus 5x squared
plus 24x and then these cancel out so
that's what we are left with and so
that's the inside of our integral so
we're going to take the integral of this
thing just so I don't have to keep
rewriting this thing from zero until if
I remember correctly 3 yep from 0 to 3
from 0 to 3 of this DX and then we had a
PI out front here we had a PI out front
here so I'll just take that out of the
integral so times pi times pi well now
we just have to take the antiderivative
and this is going to be equal to pi
times pi times antiderivative of X to
the fourth is X to the fifth over five
antiderivative 4x to the third is
actually X to the fourth so this is
going to be minus X to the fourth you
can verify that derivative is 4x and
then you decrement the exponent 4x to
the third so that works out and then the
antiderivative of this is negative 5/3 X
to the third just incremented the
exponent and divided by that and then
you have plus let's see plus 24x squared
over 2 or
12x squared and we're going to evaluate
that I like to match colors for my
opening and closing closing parentheses
we're going to evaluate that actually
let me do it as brackets we're going to
evaluate that from 0 to 3 0 to 3 so this
is going to be equal to PI times let's
evaluate all this business at let's
evaluate all this business at 3 so we're
going to get 3 to the fifth power 3 to
the fifth power so let's see 3 to the 3
to the 3rd 3 to the third is equal to 27
3 to the fourth is equal to 81 3 to the
fifth is going to be equal to this times
3 is 243 so it's going to be 243 it's
going to be some hairy math 243 over 5
minus well 3 to the 4th is 81 minus 81
minus let's see we have we're going to
have 3 to the 3rd tied let's see so it's
going to be minus 5 over 3 times 3 to
the third power so times 27 well 27
divided by 3 is just 9 9 times 5 is 45
so let's just simplify that so this is
going to be equal to 45 did I do that
right yeah it's essentially going to be
like 3 squared times 5 because you're
dividing by 3 here so it's going to have
45 and then finally 3 squared is 9 9
times 12 is 108 so plus 108 these
problems that I involve hairy arithmetic
are always the most stressful for me but
I'll try not to get too too stressed and
then we're going to subtract out this
whole thing evaluated at 0 but lucky for
us that's pretty simple this evaluated 0
0 0 0 0 so we're going to subtract out 0
which simplifies things a good bit so
now we just have to do some hairy
fraction arithmetic so let's do it
so what I'm going to do first is
simplify all of this part and then I'm
going to worry about putting it over a
denominator of 5 so let's see what we
have we have negative 81 minus 45 so
these 2 right
over here become negative one negative
126 and the negative 126 plus 108 well
that's just going to be the same thing
as negative 26 plus 8 which is going to
be negative 18 so this whole thing
simplifies to negative 18 did I do that
right did I do that right so this is
negative 126 and then negative 126 yes
it will be negative 18 so now we just
have to write negative 18 over 5
negative 18 over 5 is the same thing as
negative this is to see 5 times 1 5
times 10 is 50 plus 40 so that's going
to be negative 90 over 5 so this whole
thing has simplified to it's equal to PI
times 2 43 over 5 243 over 5 minus 90
over 5 minus 90 over 5 which is equal to
PI guys I deserve a drum roll now this
was some hairy mathematics so 243 minus
and 90 is going to be 153 153 over 5 or
we can write this as 153 PI over 5 and
after all that math you sometimes forget
what we were doing in the first place we
were figuring out this right over here
is the volume is the volume of this
figure that had this little inside of it
bored out